okay
so
what about bachelorette party cheating
no no no no no no no no
because you can do that right but you
the one thing I don't want to see is my
my girlfriend that's in the relationship
outside with a bunch of single girls
because as especially if your girls are
pretty and you're pretty gang you know
what I'm trying to say too if you're one
of them girls you're going to go outside
you're going to get attention now if my
girl is out with two of her friends or
three other friends and there's four of
them or five of them and she's in
relationship and they're out and you
know they're getting male attention
that's fine they're allowed to get that
but now my my girl's in the vicinity of
this in it and we don't want this and a
lot of guys a lot of times women will
say oh no that's controlling but this is
what we created to like we treat a woman
your high value woman you we treat you
like as a Bugatti let's say you're my
Bugatti right the most expensive because
I'm gonna compare you to Bugatti you
know I mean yeah we're gonna compare to
Bugatti so the most expensive car in the
world right
like I'm not gonna pop my Bugatti in for
example
um Hackney or something and the girl
party and we like happening but I I'm
not gonna do that even though that my
car's got the best safety in the world
even though it even though that no one
can get into it I'm not gonna risk that
you're not gonna risk that because
someone can still try to scratch my
Bugatti someone could still have to
break the window my Bugatti in actual
fact you might meet the best coffee from
the world and they might actually get
away with your Bugatti and that's how I
consider stuff to be so why would you
want your woman in any place where she
could put herself or someone could
scratch off someone could steal her so
okay so just to paraphrase cheating yes
no no I wouldn't say cheese okay so for
the for the boys going clubbing cheating
yes or no no no yeah yes 100 okay wait
raise your hand if you think it's
cheating for a man to go clubbing in a
regular place or just one yeah it just
depends like you know like Club it like
I don't I don't really know what the
London clubs are but like
is there is there a big Club in London
yes whatever the big Club in London is
ish that's the name oh no let's just go
Mayfair oh Mayfair okay he's going to
Mayfair is he cheating every week yeah
let's let's say let's let's Crank It Up
This is why I said if if I was I need a
yes or no from everyone no cheating no
it's not cheesy
okay okay so now you can go
no that's what the whole board is
basically well the way I'm looking at is
because
I'm with my girl now and I know she's a
she's good to me she's a good girl so I
would let her go clubbing I'll let her
have Instagram because I put my trust in
her and I say to her all the time you
can do all of this but if I see anything
dodgy don't come back crying when I say
it's over but that's me putting my trust
in her because I know that she's a
beautiful girl she's gonna get loads of
attention I feel like when you're with a
guy like you like you don't really want
to do that I feel like that's the
difference
if I'm with you what am I going to the
club for
I think I think going clubbing is is
actually a good thing
friend's birthday it's like it's good
for your mental health as well that's
good for your mental health
no don't do things
when I say mental health it's nice to go
out have fun let your hair that I'm a
mother yeah I've got a nine-year-old
daughter and for me letting myself lose
going out of my girls go go into a bar
or a club once in a while I'm not
talking I'm not saying every weekend
bottom line I'm still a mother but
um once in a while I go out of my girls
have a good time have a drink there's no
problem advice
we gotta stop over talking me all right
why don't you go to Applebee's all right
do you guys have Applebee's here like
you can just go go out to dinner with
your friends yeah and like have a nice
dinner
I feel like sometimes it's an energy
thing though like for example this
summer I was quite down and then
Carnival came and it was just yeah
it was something like the vibe of
Carnival it took me away
um
no no hold on hold on hold on
I saw what happened at carnival that's a
motive she's referring to clubbing are
you I'm not I'm just saying like what
I'm referring to what she was yeah
it's a Vibe like it's a it's a yeah
sometimes it's just an energy thing like
yeah wow the board is saying clubbing
we know that I'm just referring to what
she's saying which she was saying that
yeah everyone needs once in a while
I don't like what do I gotta go to eat
no do you have children no then yes
do I want my mom going to the club
I would be embarrassed if my mom went
clubbing that would be embarrassing to
me and this is a thing like like it's
crazy because the fact that you don't
understand that when you're in a
relationship you need to do some things
that you didn't do when you when you
were saying like do things you didn't do
when you're single right so it's like
you cannot be outside the same way you
was because when I see girls like
outside and they say I got a man from
like what are you doing outside I
actually always say to like where's your
man now and then you put yourself in a
scenario where you can continuously have
you ever heard when they say I was drunk
oh yeah I didn't mean to do that that's
never happened in a sober thing when
someone was outside at Applebee's for
example it always happens when you put
yourself in places where the alcohol
with these drugs where there's all these
types of things then you made a mistake
you cannot make a mistake when you're
coherent when you're not around certain
things so do you think a woman's any
much better for just staying at home
constantly
the point I don't think that's the point
at all I think the point is why as a
woman when you have these
responsibilities why would you go and
put yourself in a situation where other
men are going to look at you and want to
take you home for sexual growth then
that's the point it talks about how you
could go to Nando's you literally could
go to Nando's and have fun with your
guys
but I understand that you want to go
have fun you don't actually have to go
up to a place where there's loads of men
but I think you understand that meant a
lot that's how you conduct yourself
yeah I generally think that's how you
conduct yourself how you portray your
sub I can go I might go Mayfair I might
go carnivore but I'm not leaving any
numbers
it is it's just like you gave it if
you're at least manipulated then yeah
maybe club club is not for you yeah but
it's like it's like you're going it's
like you're going to a bunch of
potential okay you're a car right like
this is analogy I know women aren't cars
but this is always the first thing but
it's like it's like you're going to the
dealership where there's potential
buyers and saying I'm for sale and just
because you didn't sell out you're
saying oh well you're easily manipulated
if you don't sell out yeah but you still
went to the dealership we're better buy
it
listen go to a bar or club or whatever
even Carnival you want to listen to good
music you want to be around your girls
you want to have a drink you want to
listen I mean there's nothing wrong
it's only an issue when you make it
Friday Saturday Sunday
that's a problem then I'm gonna look at
my partner who's like what's up
in this context yeah there's you're
referring to that as your but what
you're understanding is that it's her
advice that that's the same thing as me
choosing to go to Pottery every week
when there's Mandan there as well I
think it's the same thing no one's
looking for sexual classification for me
yes every question for the boys guys
stop stop I have a question for the boys
do you go to a pottery class to get laid
no do you go to a club to get laid
you gotta stop interrupting me do you go
to Carnival to get laid so no so
basically I I got to ask you because I
went I went Carnival my goal in it so I
went Carnival so but
you've got a man did you go Carnival
with your man no red flag
hold on hold on what do you realize yeah
just by having my girl like two steps
away from me do you know what I asked my
partner do you want to go Carnival he
said no that's not his style I said okay
I'm gonna go I want to go Carnival so
there was a communication there that's
it like I asked him he said no he didn't
want to go I'll be happy to go huh did
you give any words up me yeah no I would
I did not no I'm just asking because
some people don't no but I don't go away
I go Carnival for the cultures
oh I'm going to go Carnival okay to go
and meet me okay I get it I get it
what'd you say it's catching on giving a
wine you know Carnival wine what's a
wine Dirty Dancing
no I was doing interviews I didn't
realize oh is that the twerking thing
they be like yeah so when they're like
the girls
but you see me you see me like to me
that's cheating the people at carnival
say no it's cultural but like that's not
that's for me okay I'll add that rub it
up I love this thing is
that's inappropriate because I wouldn't
want my I wouldn't want my significant
other partner or anyone to be dancing
like how many man moves do you kind of
please just be on the stock cap just be
honest how many man approach to be
honest bear man right yeah
exactly the fact that you even put
yourself in that you know
that Carnival is a celebrity if you're
from the Caribbean it's a celebrity
[Music]
at that point as many of you know I was
just banned on Tic Tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible